what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
you know here's a crazy thing where I
say that I've been reading Marvel Comics
for you know 20-something years a huge
bulk of that has been the x-men I mean I
always loved the x-men they were just my
favorite t-mike they're one of my
favorite groups really did existed in
mobile comics I read other stuff just
out of curiosity about what it was about
but like the meat and potatoes of most
of my knowledge when it comes to Marvel
comics is the x-men and this story is
amazing it's sad but it's really really
amazing
so the juggernaut of course is one of
the more popular foes of the x-men I
mean in a lot of ways I would argue he's
more of the arch-nemesis of Charles
Xavier by extension the x-men but
magneto is still probably the most
popular villain when people think of
like the main enemy of the x-men they
think of Magneto and rightfully so I
mean he was the first major villain they
faced but with regards to juggernaut
he's always been this sort of wrecking
ball he's not very smart but his history
with his stepbrother Charles Xavier
created a lot of animosity between the
two and so because of the fact that they
bickered and they argued and came Arco
hated Charles once he became the
juggernaut you know during the Korean
War when he picked up the crimson gem of
cyttorak and you know he got that whole
transcription you know whosoever touches
this gym shall receive the power of the
crimson bands of cyttorak or whatever it
is henceforth you who read these words
shall go forevermore a human juggernaut
sup along those lines I'm paraphrasing
but the fact remains once he became a
juggernaut he was like this unstoppable
force and it was kind of cool because in
Marvel Comics the juggernaut literally
lives up to his words in almost every
conceivable way there was for example a
time with The Incredible Hulk defeated
the juggernaut didn't really defeat him
but managed to push him back which was
supposed to be impossible but it took
the Incredible Hulk modified with
celestial technology at the hands of
apocalypse in order to make that happen
again and that all goes into the nature
of the fact that Sid Iraq is one of
these old demonic entities that exist in
Marvel Comics it's a wildly powerful
being but in terms of the juggernaut
he's an avatar as if Sid Iraq we're
walking around the world now juggernaut
is not nearly as powerful as Sid Iraq
but it's still kind of cool because what
this story does is it basically comes
after the events of x-men number eleven
back in 1965 written by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby now the idea behind x-men
number eleven is that it basically
introduced this I'm pretty sure it
introduced the character of this
stranger and the stranger is just one of
those cosmic entities that exists out
there and he's literally called a
stranger because nothing's known about
him he's just a being who's there he's
got cosmic powers and that's really
about it but in that story the stranger
had shown up on earth and basic
we kidnapped Magneto and the toad and
whisked them off to his own planet just
explore and you know just study them and
so it was kind of cool in terms of how
that little bit a little bit worked but
what this story does is it takes place
in the interim
when magneto is off planted alongside
toad and initially opens out with this
bit of an explanation all the Avengers
are dead Thor's dead Iron Man's dead
Captain America's debt and standing over
them all is the juggernaut now the
initial indication here is that the
juggernauts the one that did them all in
but then we end up finding out that it
was actually the Sentinels that
basically killed off all these different
superheroes and it's kind of cool when
we get to see like juggernaut versus the
Sentinels because what did he keep in
mind is that different riders interpret
the powers of characters differently and
it's all contextual and based on what
story they want to tell for example in
this story djebena
rips through these signals I mean it's
no challenge at all and he's got super
strength he's virtually unstoppable once
he stops to move on once he starts
moving he's not indestructible one of
them makes a comment they have like less
than 1% of a chance to actually survive
the experience like 110 thousand third
one one hundred thousandth of a percent
and in surviving the experience it was
kind of cool because were they trying to
take off juggernaut grabs him basically
kind of dragged him back down and and
you know completely and totally pummels
him but if we go and read a story like
Days of Future past that was a story
Chris Claremont wrote an uncanny x-men
141 142 I think it was it was basically
the worst case scenario it was an answer
to the question what would happen if
mutants fail if Xavier was killed and
Senator Robert Kelly was killed what
would happen if they were assassinated
by the mutants and what would happen if
humanity responded by jump-starting The
Sentinel program and the signals went at
Ron it was a doomsday scenario it was
the worst case situation for Earth and
more for the mutants than anything else
because they failed in their entirety
and so the Days of Future past led to
the Sentinels more or less modifying
their own programming becoming
autonomous and then just wiping out the
entirety of humanity mutants and
otherwise and that was really about it I
mean you had a few little you know rebel
factions here and there and of course
that led into you know Rachel summers
the daughter of Jean Grey and Cyclops
from Days of Future past sitting the
mind of Kitty Pryde into the past to
stop the whole thing from happening but
still the idea was that you know signals
had basically conquered earth and so
when you go and you read that story
juggernauts long since been dead he was
eradicated by the symbols and
consolidating those two things is kind
of difficult because if his power was
has basically always been the same if
for the most part up until eighth day up
until Tryon his powers were basically
consistent across the board
how do you justify those two things and
there's really no way that you can you
just kind of have to roll with the
punches and just say hey look it just
Legos different writers want to tell
different stories but the cool thing
about this is that juggernaut gives us a
lot of inner monologue in terms of how
he views things in the sense that the
juggernaut was always very selfishly
motivated in a lot of ways I mean he had
a few friends here and they're like
block Tom Cassidy for example you know
who for the most part resided in Cassidy
keep but for the most part Jabbar not
was largely just kind of a lone wolf out
there by himself doing whatever it is
that he wanted to do because he could he
was more or less a bully who received
these almost godlike powers in terms of
strength durability speed movement
different things like that and so as a
result you know with him basically
losing everybody believing that
everybody out there is completely and
totally dead he actually goes back to
the Xavier Institute and this is a human
of Cain Marko I mean he is human in and
of himself he just has incredible powers
by way of the gym but he almost seems
inhuman in terms of how he acts no one
can stop the juggernaut he's this
unstoppable force he doesn't seem to be
human but then when he shows up here he
basically has this sort of connection
with Charles Xavier or his argument is
yes I hated them yes I hated the x-men
yes I hated Charles Xavier but I would
do anything to be able to talk to them
again because I am just so absolutely
lonely he misses his connection with
humanity because it's the one thing that
he never really seemed to have before
you know and so because of this what he
ends up doing is he basically ends up
walking the earth for like days and
weeks and years hodges passes it just
sort of blurs together and all he can do
is just travel around the world and look
at all these different shamble bits and
pieces these relics of humanity and so
you know finally he comes across this
old Sentinel bay city long since
destroyed and the signals begin coming
to life only for us to realize they're
being controlled by magneto and so this
is cool because this is how this feeds
in to x-men issue number 11 an
expedition number 11 and that's story
written in 1965 magneto managed to
finally get out you know managed to to
basically make his way back to earth in
this story events unfolded almost the
exact same way in the sense that magneto
is being studied by the stranger but he
also gained access to a lot of the
different devices that the stranger had
as a cosmic entity he's come across all
different manner of devices from
different alien races things he's made
on his own and what these things allowed
and that needed to do was basically look
at the earth and see what was going on
and what we end up finding out here is
that when the Sentinels began their
campaign and they started going around
and killing all these different
superheroes that from Magneto's
perspective juggernaut just kind of wash
it all unfold he just basically stood
back and watched it all happen while
juggernaut didn't necessarily kill the
Avengers or the x-men himself his
inaction allowed it to happen but then
we get like this massive revelation what
we end up finding out is that somewhere
along the line when juggernaut
presumably first you know became a major
villain for the x-men he showed up at
the Xavier Institute and he basically
killed all the x-men not only that you
know when he killed the x-men when he
killed Charles Xavier the whole nine
yards when the Sentinel program was
reinitiated when it all jump-started
again there was nobody there to warn the
Avengers to warn the Fantastic Four the
Sentinels just kind of popped up out of
nowhere and where the x-men have
consistently fought the Sentinels and
where the x-men are best suited to
defeat the signal's because of their
knowledge about the civils design the
x-men weren't there because juggernaut
killed them and so because of that there
was no one left to defend humanity there
was nobody left there to save humans and
so as the seminoles began going through
and wiping out humans what signals began
to realize is that humans do procreate
at a ridiculous rate and so because of
that it would basically take too long
and the earth would be almost eradicated
in his entirety virtually uninhabitable
if the campaign went on and so when they
ended up doing was in an effort to
basically eliminate as many humans as
possible they basically modified their
own cells to emit a kind of radiation
and so the earth itself is just
blanketed in all this radiation and
that's what killed all the humans that's
what killed everybody it was basically
the juggernaut who killed the x-men
which led to the deaths of almost
everything in existence but the reason
why I say almost is because in the
juggernauts rage at this revelation the
fact that he's the one that basically
led to everything coming to an end he
starts freaking out stomping on the
ground only to fall down into this
cavern and discover the Iceman Bobby
Drake now this is kind of cool in terms
of how this feeds on ice man's history
historically speaking Bobby Drake has
always been a little bit reckless and a
little bit just sort of headstrong and
more of the jokester than anything else
he's very much indicative of like your
stereotypical teenager you know and
because of that he never really applied
himself the way that he needed to now
that also went into the idea of why it
is the Bobby Drake was so popular but
with him failing to basically focus and
harness his abilities the way that he
should because this is relatively early
in the days of the x-men this meant that
once Charles Xavier died there was no
one there to teach Bobby Drake how to
use his powers as over the most part he
can't control his abilities and in this
instance you know where he says I can
only maintain this current form for a
few moments at a time
the amount of harm that he maintains it
goes on too long and he basically
encases himself in ice and he can't get
out he can't shut his powers down but
because of the fact that Bobby Drake had
basically made reference to the fact
that there are people here juggernaut
and his desire to see more of humanity
and his desire to experience a
connection smashes through Bobby Drake
and then smashes through the door and of
course when he shows up we end up
finding out that characters like
Quicksilver or alive Scarlet Witch is a
live toad who's basically sort of this
jokey henchman of magneto or alive and
there's a few other mutants here and
there but there's also a lot of people
and that's kind of the irony of all this
because what Toad tells us is that when
magneto came back to earth and realized
the Sentinels were basically running
amuck
they were wiping out humanity in the
process wiping out whatever mutants were
left basically killing everything they
could find magneto and toad grabbed as
many people as they could human or
mutant threw him into their ship and
then whisked him off to this location to
basically create a safe haven of sorts
and so with this this radiation
spreading throughout the world they
effectively created a bunker that
protected them from it but the irony is
that with Jever not showing up and
juggernaut smashing down the door in his
effort to experience and to talk to more
people he doomed them all to death he's
basically doomed the last remnants of
humanity and mutants to die at the hands
of his toxic radiation because he wanted
to see them so badly and that goes into
the nature of the juggernaut right I
mean he'd be he leaps before he looks
and he doesn't think about what's
actually happened he just does things
and then whatever happens happens and so
despite the fact that he was longing for
a connection that he actually broke into
this place intending no ill will
he dooms what's left of humanity he
basically killed everybody on earth as
it was kind of cool because in this
scenario he's basically forced his sort
of walk off live just kind of exists
because he doesn't need food he doesn't
need water he's effectively immortal so
long as he's was in possession of the
Crimson Jim the juggernaut is the last
man on earth that's it there's no one
left the last vestiges the last little
tidbits of whoever was alive were in
that bunker and they're all dying now I
mean their reserve they've got minutes
and so because of that he's just doomed
to walk the earth forever until the
Earth's destruction or its repopulated
or whatever the case may be and so again
it's pretty dark and it's pretty messed
up to me it's one of the coolest
juggernaut stories is out there so with
that being said guys when you go ahead
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come let's explain and
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob cork if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you draw
like and it will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you